- Fake talking cat, just
what we need around here.
- [Narrator] Salem from
"Sabrina the Teenage Witch"
graced our screens in the '90s.
- Salem, guard my door so
Jenny doesn't go anywhere, OK?
- Hey, dogs guard.
Cats watch and judge.
- [Narrator] For the
actor behind the sass,
playing the role of a
puppet suited him just fine.
- Puppets can get away with murder.
Don't ever do a scene with
them, no one's looking at you.
(cat meow)
Oh, ho ho.
I'm having a bad fur day.
Hi, I'm Nick Bakay, and I'm
best known probably as the voice
of Salem, the talking cat on
"Sabrina the Teenage Witch."
- Hit it, cat.
♪ And I've got no defense ♪
- Salem was a very frustrated guy
who tried to take over the world.
His punishment was they turned
him into a cat for 100 years.
There was a lovely
bitterness to the character
that I leaned into hard.
- Salem, you're the only
one who understands me.
- Yeah, but it doesn't mean I care.
- You know, I was in the
writer's room on that show too,
so I could pitch my own jokes.
- Maybe I should take your temperature.
- Under the tongue, under the tongue.
- Alright, I'll check in a few minutes.
- [Nick] I was onset doing the
voice live first four years.
Took a village to do that
cat because then you had
animal trainers and a
multitude of live cats.
- Up and down and up.
- And there was a remarkable
crew of puppeteers.
Our head puppeteer was Tom
Founders who is really gifted.
He ran the mouth and we had
Maury who moved the body,
and she spent her days in
darkness jammed into that kitchen
island counter, you know,
just working that body.
It was a real team effort.
- [Narrator] But Nick is
more than just a cat voice.
- I was also the voice of Norbert.
- Don't mess with the bull, my friend.
You'll get the horns.
- [Nick] The big older brother
on the Nickelodeon
cartoon "Angry Beavers."
I've been a writer/producer
on a bunch of shows
like "King of Queens."
I also wrote the Paul
Barton Mall Cop movies
with my pal, Kevin James.
- You're a nasty old man.
- [Narrator] And he's been
in front of the camera, too.
On some well-known shows like Seinfeld.
- No.
- No, here.
Just--
- Please.
- [Narrator] That '70s Show.
♪ I'm been cheating ♪
- [Narrator] And this AOL ad.
- Thanks to America Online,
I'm really just goofing off.
(laughing)
This is back during my
trying-to-make-my-career-
as-an-actor phase.
You did some deep dig there, huh?
- So, it looks like it's just you and me.
Wanna do each other's hair?
- I love cats.
I've had cats my whole life.
Up until very recently
we had a cat named Salem.
A little black cat who
we rescued for 16 years.
I tried to make friends with my namesake.
It wasn't in the cards.
Hated my guts.
(laughing)